The Joe Rogan Experience first of all
what was it like uh to get a hold of the
Twitter files like what what was that
experience like how did that go down
exciting as hell man I mean seriously uh
there's been a lot of misinformation
about that itself but Barry Weiss
contacted me
um she lives in LA and she got in and
she's like how soon can you get over
here and I was like let me finish this
interview I'm on and I'm over
and yeah it was incredible
um you know I never met Elon before you
know I met him at the coffee station
just making himself a cup of coffee he
had no idea who I was and
yeah we just got into it it was a you
know I was sort of the the least known
of the big three journalists that were
there it was Barry Weiss and Matt taiibi
who was on
and they'd already started thinking
about how to kind of what to go after
and Matt had done a story on the hunter
Biden laptop already
um and then we were starting to look at
January 6th because Trump gets
de-platformed on January 8th and so
because I'm like the junior member of
that uh threesome so to speak they gave
me January 7th so the first thing we one
of the first things we did was just to
look at how they made a decision to get
to pull Trump off the platform
and it turned out that the seventh was
an important day because that was when
they started to rationalize this
decision to de-platform Trump even
though their own people inside had
decided that he had not violated their
terms of service so they were sort of
stuck making up a reason to be platform
and that was an important theme was that
they just kept changing the rules
basically to to do what they wanted to
do and that was the same thing on the
hunter Biden laptop the New York Post
story that they censored also had not
violated their terms of service
so I mean look it was crazy I mean it
was uh you know there's people always
ask questions about the about the files
themselves but you know the experience
was we would ask for these searches and
we just get back huge amounts of data it
was lots of thousands and thousands of
emails thousands of internal messages on
their slack messaging system
and so yeah I mean a lot of it was you
know some of it was very boring because
you have to just read tons and tons of
stuff but you know we I think the big
theme was we start by seeing a real you
know is it super Progressive it's like
99 of campaign contributions from
Twitter staff are going to Democrats
you know the head of safety at Twitter
this guy named Joel Roth
who you know said you know said there's
actual Nazis in the White House when
Trump came in he's very Progressive
but over time we just kept finding like
this weird like FBI wants us to do this
you know there's these other government
agencies oh you know this uh all these
people used to work at the FBI uh the
CIA shows up Department of Homeland
Security and we're kind of like what the
hell is going on and
the story quickly shifted from us sort
of and I think what Elon thought which
was that it was just very Progressive
people being biased in their content
moderation and their censoring to there
is a huge operation by U.S government
officials U.S government contractors and
all of these super sketchy ngos getting
money from who knows where
basically demanding that Twitter start
censoring people and at that moment the
story shifted for all of us and that was
I think where taibi became particularly
important
and sort of the lead because he had had
so much experience on sort of looking at
how the US government during the war on
terror had waged disinformation
campaigns propaganda campaigns and it
became clear to us you know over time
that the US government had turned its
propaganda and disinformation campaigns
that had been waging abroad
it turned them against the American
people and that was where you just sort
of get chills up your spine and you were
like this is something seriously
Sinister is going on
do we know when this began like when did
they infiltrate these organizations
because I'm sure it's not just Twitter
right I'm sure it's oh no absolutely not
that's part of what was so terrifying is
that it was all of the social media
companies including Wikipedia by the way
which we don't talk enough about but
also all of the mainstream news
organizations are all being organized so
when does it start you know it really
what you're looking at is the apparatus
that was created by the war on terror
over the last 20 years starting after 9
11 then there was a battle against Isis
because Isis was successfully recruiting
on social media so there was sort of a
counter Isis recruiting campaign that
occurred
then you get the big event is brexit
2016 Trump's election in 2016 and the
establishment just freaks out absolutely
freaks out and they there's a lot of
different motivations here so one of the
motivations is just to blame Facebook
blame social media for Trump's Victory
it was never true I don't really think
anybody really believed it there's just
you know it just there was just for a
variety of reasons we can talk about
there was never any good evidence that
the whatever Russians did had much of
any influence any measurable influence
on the outcome of the campaign
but they started to scapegoat the the
social media companies as a way to get
control over them and so then they
started then in 2017 they set up well
two things happen or many things happen
the Department of Homeland Security
just declares
election infrastructure to be part of
their mission of protecting election
infrastructure and that meant protecting
the media environment protecting
protecting put it that in quotes you
know it's creepy it's patronizing
it's a power move
so that's the first thing that happens
they create something called the cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency within the Department of Homeland
Security
to supposedly protect the media
environment from foreign influence they
create something called the the foreign
influence task force with the FBI to
basically start policing domestic speech
on these platforms
they start organizing all the social
media companies to participate in these
meetings so you had Mark Zuckerberg the
CEO of Facebook in here and he says to
you there's this critical moment where
you ask about the hunter buying laptop
and he goes well yeah
um you know in the summer of 2020 all
these FBI guys come to us saying there's
going to be a hack and leak operation
involving Hunter Biden which is super
suspicious because as everybody now
knows the FBI had Hunter Biden's laptop
in December 2019.
what freaked me out and I was I had so
by the way I was a victim of the hunter
Biden laptop disinformation I thought
that I voted for Biden I thought that it
was a I thought that that laptop was
Russian disinformation I just bought the
whole thing and this is some from
somebody who
you're a journalist I'm supposedly a
journalist right
so call journalist I bought it you know
I'm still a big liberal in so many ways
and everybody I knew was like oh you
know and besides trump it was just he's
so for all the reasons that progressives
bought that the laptop was fake I bought
that it was fake so so then when you
realize that it was real and that
everything in that New York Post story
on October 14 2020 was was accurate
I started seeing stuff in the emails the
thing that really freaked me out was
this thing that Aspen Institute a call
it's called a tabletop exercise and it
was actually a zoom call
to role play how to deal with a Russian
Hack and leak around Hunter Biden this
is like in June of 2020 so this is like
months before the New York before months
before Rudy Giuliani gets that the
laptop before Rudy Giuliani gives the
laptop to New York Post why in the hell
is Aspen Institute holding a tabletop
exercise to pre-bunk basically they are
training or brainwashing all these
journalists and I mean it's CNN New York
Times Washington Post Wikimedia
Foundation the Wikipedia folks the
networks all of the social media
companies all coming together to be like
okay well if something is if something
is leaked then we should not cover it in
the way that journalists have
traditionally covered it meanwhile
Stanford University a few a few months
earlier had put out a report saying
reporters should no longer follow the
Pentagon papers principle well the
Pentagon papers of course is famous
episode it was Steven Spielberg made a
whole movie about it where the
Washington Post and New York Times
published these internal Pentagon
documents showing that the US government
was losing the war in Vietnam right this
is Daniel Ellsberg and he just releases
it he steals these documents he breaks
the law steals these documents gives
them to the newspapers the newspapers
publish them
it's this kind of incredible moment in
American journalism where we are like
the first amendment gives these
newspapers the right to publish uh
hacked so-called hacked but leaked
information and here you have Stanford
University Aspen Institute saying oh no
no that's all we should stop doing that
journalists should no longer
write about leaked information in that
way instead we should focus on the
person who leaked it so it's it really
sent chills on my spine you know it was
just it was the creepiest thing I'd ever
seen and and this is of course you gotta
remember asking who's funded by the US
government yeah Stanford's funded by the
US government so this is people go oh
well you're just one of the responses
we've got is they go oh you're just
talking about you know content
moderation by private companies no we're
talking about U.S government-funded
organizations
you can't if the US government is
censoring information that's obviously a
violation of First Amendment but if the
US government is funding somebody else
to censor information that's also a
violation of the First Amendment you
can't indirectly it's still a violation
if you're if you're funding somebody to
demand censorship so
that was quite a steeple chase but
there's a lot here I mean it's a lot a
lot of people a lot of Institutions a
lot to unpack and that was part of the
reason I wanted to reach out and be like
we just I need a Joe Rogan session to
just kind of go through it all yeah well
I'm very happy to provide that um here's
the question
the obviously the laptop would harm uh
the hunter Biden laptop would harm Joe
Biden obviously and if that story got
out who knows how many people would have
voted the other way is this a direct
result of the things that Trump said
when he was in office that went against
the intelligence Community like how did
they decide I would always assume that
you know the the so-called deep state is
essentially a bipartisan that they they
wouldn't necessarily side with the
Democrats or the Republicans that really
you know they're just in charge of
they're supposed to be gathering
information to protect the country so
how did they decide specifically to
either
um either stop information or propagate
misinformation that would Aid Joe Biden
yeah
yes that is exactly the right question
so I mean I think the thing you have to
understand is that
that Trump was viewed by the Deep state
by
you know CIA FBI you know I mean all of
the elites and and this and you're right
it's bipartisan in the sense that it's
both never Trump Republicans and
Democrats
what freaked them out the most about
Trump is that he was threatening to pull
the us out of NATO I don't think that
that was I just think that was Bluster
like that's insane like and by the way I
should say
I actually I support what we call the
Western Alliance I support providing
military security for our allies in Asia
and in Europe I'm not a
I mean there's parts of economic
nationalism that I respect but I'm also
I don't I don't think we should pull out
of NATO I think NATO has provided peace
in the world and and mostly been a good
thing it's obviously had some crazy
abuses like Iraq
this whole experience has made me
rethink my support for for Ukraine but I
think it's important to understand that
Trump terrified the Deep state of the
National Security establishment so did
brexit there's a sense in which you had
a guy on here named Peter Zion who wrote
this book called this really apocalyptic
book about how the world is going to
fall apart and his whole argument which
I don't agree with I think he's
brilliant but the book is I think the
argument's wrong his little argument is
based on the idea the United States is
going to stop providing military
security to our allies in Asia and
Europe it's all just based on this
assumption that Trump is the beginning
of some
the U.S withdrawing from its traditional
role since World War II
there's a bunch of people who obviously
their their ideology their their
livelihoods their identity just their
whole way of life is tied up with
providing the United States providing
this protect this protection for you
know Europe and Asia and and they view
Trump as threatening that I also think
they just really hated the guy they
looked down on him you know it was crude
and all the things that that yeah that
people don't like about it he spoke
disparagingly about the intelligence
Community yeah I mean he was just crazy
absolutely he was against the war in
Iraq he he was uh different he was a
nationalist
Republican and what's so interesting is
that you know if you read people like
you know people on the left like Noam
Chomsky and others who have been critics
of U.S or Glenn Greenwald who are
critics of or anything Matt taibi
critics of US Government you know
military
invasions around the world since World
War II I mean we've overthrown many
governments right uh you know Iran Chile
Guatemala you know and and what the
pattern is is that these are places
where nationalists sometimes socialists
but often just nationalists who are
trying to control their economies and
they didn't want foreign interference
were coming to power and the US
government would see that as a threat to
providing you know having this
this liberal Global order as it's called
and so
they saw what Trump they saw Trump as an
existential threat to this post-war
liberal order and they needed to they
and they viewed social media as the
means to his power which I think was
exaggerated so on the one hand they saw
a threat I think they also saw an
opportunity you know the war on terror
we we won I mean like it's just I mean
we huge huge Victory I mean it's
shocking how successful it was in some
ways so you have a bunch of people that
suddenly need something to do
um so there's a lot of motivations there
and then you also have the guys that
lost the Hillary campaign John podesta
he was their chair of her campaign he
runs the most powerful Progressive
frankly propaganda organization in the
world or at least in the United States
the center for American progress they
were looking also for some reason
someone to blame for their own failures
you know for the dislikability of
Hillary
and so there was just a lot of
motivations to try to get control over
social media platforms they felt like
they had lost control of them